hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar comprehensive capture of
human neural pathology by multiplexed
ion beam imaging I'm Alexis Kraus of
leverage and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by ion path
clamp app is revolutionizing the
analysis of tissue biopsies with
multiplex ion beaming imaging to learn
more about ion path please visit ww-why
be a calm now let's get started
you can post questions to the speaker
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind to do so simply type
them into the drop down box located on
the far left ear screen labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of the presentation window
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problems like typing it into
the answer question box located on the
far left of your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credit I now
present today's speaker Shaun Bendele
PhD assistant professor at Stanford
University of pathology
dr. Randall is an expert in protein
biochemistry mass spectrometry and stem
cell biology and single-cell analysis
his lab creates new methods for single
cell proteomics that are applied to
human cells stem cell biology cancer
immunology and neurodegenerative disease
dr. Bendel will now begin his
presentation
you
all right I'm going to start by
everybody for logging into the
presentation today a little bit more
about myself I'm uh I'm a biochemist in
stem cell biologist by training and you
know my lab develops a lot of single
cell tech proteomic technologies
including the multiplex IBM imaging and
so what I'm gonna tell you today is a
new area of industrial I'm going to talk
a little a little bit about a new area
we've been in we've been investigating
we're you know classically we've kind of
looked at the hematopoiesis tum' tumor
immunology I'm gonna tell you a little
bit more about what we've been doing
with neuropathology and the reason why
neuropathology is interesting but also
challenging is because you know it's
it's a really complex tissue and it has
a lot of complex issues to go along with
it and you know the real challenge is is
when you're thinking about you know most
of our analysis most imaging type
applications you do you know using
fluorescence can be great but you know
as this slide kind of highlights here
even just doing low color fluorescence
imaging on an unstained field view you
can see you get beautiful differential
autofluorescence on on central nervous
system tissue here and this is because
the brain is naturally full of auto
fluorescent compounds and there's
certain things like molecules like lip
of Hewson that actually build up
naturally in the brain with age and so
these can be extremely challenging
outside of fairly heroic sample
preparation techniques to deal with so
you know as a lot of people who are
probably listening or are aware you know
technologies like multiplex IBM imaging
go and they they swap out the use of
floor force for elemental mass reporters
and I tell you a little bit more about
about this so originally when we when we
kind of went when working with Mike
Angelo here at Stanford we kind of came
up with this idea that the the the the
the short version of it is is you know
you have your tissue your tissues
mounted on a surface in this case we
were using a analytical instrument
called Amanda Sims and this this surface
here was a conductive piece of silicon
we mounted the tissue on it you'd
stained
tissue with your in this case mostly
antibodies with your metal reporter
probes attached them
we've load the the conductive surface
and the instrument and then the
instrument what it does is to image to
generate the image at the nanometer
scale it scans the sample with a primary
ion beam this primary ion beam liberate
s' these elemental reporters in a
location specific manner and in the case
of the Nano cyst nano send it's a mass
spectrometer that is based on a magnetic
sector so it had up to seven detectors
where we could measure seven different
mass channels and putting this all
together we could then go and take those
elemental reporters reconstruct their
their levels and locations on the sample
and generate a histopathological image
that very much recapitulated what we
expected to see in the tissue but also
in this original paper we could actually
benchmark against other quantitative IHC
assays the so so the good part is is we
you know we could we could show that
this was a great proof of principle for
multiplex imaging that the the bad part
was and that you know this type of
instrumentation is extremely complicated
it's hard to access there was you know
we just were lucky to be at Stanford and
we happen to have one of a few of these
instruments in the United States this
relatively small field of view took a
long time to image and you know because
it was based on a magnetic sector we'd
only had a couple detectors so we could
only actually even though all of the
masses even though you could have
multiple masses there we could only
collect a few channels at the same time
so this kind of brought us to thinking
about new instrumentation and new
applications and what what what this is
resulted in is Mike and I working
together to prototype new types of
instrumentation that is now being
commercialized July and past but I'm
going to tell you a little bit about
these early academic efforts and how it
led to the new applications and
ultimately to the neuropathology stuff
like I show you at the end here so the
new the new maybe top instrumentation is
purpose-built for doing tissue imaging
and there was a couple main innovations
here the the first part on the right was
kind of obvious we went from a magnetic
sector
- putting a top bass detector what
time-of-flight does it's time of flight
lets you measure all your masses at
parallel so every time the mass spec
scans you scan the entire mass range and
so there's no limit of how many
reporters we can simultaneously measure
based on the detector the other big
innovation was this change on the left
here around the source we put a bigger
iron gun on a 45 degree angle and the
whole point was with that was to
essentially sputter more material off
over a shorter period of time so we
could sample and thus image faster and
then we add it we added this
electrostatic analyzer in where we
basically make the ions turn a corner
and the purpose for that was was to
essentially deal with some contaminants
you often get in Sims imaging which are
these kind of partially or on Anaya
NIH's Logan energy particles that you
want to kind of fill throughout because
they generate noise in your image and so
when we put all of this together we
could then go back and because of this
new configuration we were able to image
multiple markers on a much much bigger
field of view in the same amount of time
that it would take for us to get this
very very small field of view using the
original madison's
demonstration so we're pretty excited
about this and you know on top of that
you know we also have an extra you know
an extra layer of features we can
capture things like the sed image here
which gives you a surface announced the
tissue that you can then overlay with
your different metal coated importers
reporters to get these kind of pseudo
bright field fluorescence images as well
so where's his taken as some people
might have seen this paper or maybe
logged into a webinar that might gave a
couple months back but I think one of
the really exciting early studies this
enabled us to do was instead of going
instead of looking at just a couple
patient samples in a couple fields of
view like we did in the 2014 Nature
Methods nature medicine paper we were
able to go and do a larger cohort
analysis specifically a retrospective
study of triple negative breast cancer
and bear with me this is this is we're
the still leading to the neuropathology
but it kind of a kind of shows how one
type of instrument application kind of
leads to multiple downstream biological
investigations and in this particular
study what we did is we looked at a
couple fields of view across a large
number of patients and the goal here was
to really build up a rule set around the
tumor immune micro environment to see if
there was anything about what was going
on with tumor immunology and how it
might relate to kind of disease
stratification and to make a long story
short that you know what we what we
found here was across a cohort of just
over 40 patients there was really only
three favorite flavors of tissue immune
types one one one two immune type was
one basically lacking immune infiltrate
and then of the two that had immune
infiltrate they fell into these these
either finally mixed or compartmentalize
tumor types and the structures that we
saw in the tumors were also closely
linked to know expression and
localization of things like checkpoint
molecules and the cool part here was you
know after this analysis was kind of
done we went back and pulled the data
from the from the the kind of survival
data from the clinical records from the
patients that whose samples were on a
study and we actually showed that the
compartmentalize phenotype it was
present at diagnosis was strongly
predictive of overall survival with
people getting standard chemotherapy so
it was really cool in the sense that you
know you could take something like tumor
immune interaction and relate it to
overall survival in a non immunotherapy
scenario so what I wanted to give you
guys a little bit of an update on is
where we've kind of gone from there
because it leads into having to scan
larger areas and do larger scale
comparisons which again are I think
really important for know pathology so
with with with this particular study
like I said we we we sampled you know
only only single fields of view across a
large number of patients and one of the
questions we've always got was well what
about you know intramural heterogeneity
how does it vary across a tumor between
tumor sites and so we went back and we
we did it a little bit of a case study
here where we we pulled one of the
tumors from from one of those original
patients in the study you can actually
see here where the original tissue core
was sampled from this block and we went
and we did a we did a full slide scan on
the under maybe toss here and what what
this is is this is essentially a series
of approximately 500 micron tiles that
are stitched back together and this scan
is done at relatively a low resolution
where each pixel is about one micron but
when we scan at that resolution each one
of those tiles only takes a few minutes
and so in a relatively short period of
time we can get a survey scan of the
whole tumor and then go back and
pre-select these regions here of
interest and rescan them at a much much
higher resolution because again you know
this technology only actually ablates a
little bit of a sample each time a few
hundred nanometers of a few micron
tissue section and so once you've kind
of done this we can then go and zoom in
a little bit and ask some more questions
about what's going on with with tumor
and immune cell heterogeneity across
these sites and so just focusing on the
tumor cells to start here what we see is
even within a couple of these sampled
areas you see that they're there there's
change in gradients of tumor markers
like keratin changes implication changes
in abnormal expression of immune markers
like class two and so there is a strong
suggestion of heterogeneity and when we
extract the tumor cells from the image
using our segmentation pipeline we can
cluster the extracted features and
within a single tumor
we can assign multiple tumor cell
subtypes and so the question is is how
do these subtypes vary across regions
with the tuber and what we did is just
kind of visually summarize this you can
you can do dimensionality reduction in
form Disney on this and these are how
our different tumor clusters kind of
arrange in in multi-dimensional space
and then when we reveal these tumor
clusters by tumor region what I think is
this starts to highlight here is that
the identity of the tumor cell is seems
to have a regional bias where where you
know the regions and the tumor cells are
not randomly disputed and they seem to
go kind of they could be kind of
clustered together and to look at this a
little more quantitatively you can
enumerate each of each you know each of
the cell types or each of the tumor
types by region here and you can see
again there's a strong correlation
between between the region region
identity and the number of cells in it
then more importantly here this map is
hierarchically clustered so the the the
the tumor phenotypes that are most
similar to one another are close
together on the map and you can see
again that there's also a there seems to
be a spatial similarity as well to the
point where if we actually plot the
distance between tumor cells across this
whole image versus the the composition
and the correlation between composition
there's an inverse relationship
implicating that essentially the further
the tumor cells are apart from one
another in the tissue physically the
less similar they are so that was
interesting because you know kind of
outline summary of tumor heterogeneity
and it actually shows that you get a
phenotypic kind of evolution across the
tumor that is much in line with how we
think you get also clonal evolution
within the tumor now what about the
immune system so we went back to those
same fields extracted the immune cells
using the pipeline we laid out in that
original paper clustered them using flow
some to get our different immune cell
types and just to kind of you know make
a long story short here we you know
again we get very nice separation of our
different immune cell types but unlike
the tumor cell types in
case what we saw was that the immune
cells with the exception of one region
that seemed to have a lot of
neutrophilic infiltrate the immune cells
were were evenly distributed across all
the regions and the phenotypes were
evenly distributed across the regions
and so this is craisins kind of
interesting point that even though the
composition of the tumor was
phenotypically variable how the immune
system was coming in and interacting
with the tumor and all the different
points was quite conserved and so I
think that you know III think it bodes
well for for for undersampling tumors
for studying tumor immune interaction
but it also reinforces the fact that if
you want to study tumor heterogeneity
itself you have to you have to sample
much larger areas so like I said I we
were actually coming to talk about
neuropathology se but I kind of wanted
to give you an idea of what kind of a
more complete story looks at when you're
and something that's leveraging scanning
and rescanning large fields of view so
what we're doing with the brain is you
know my lab is particularly interested
in in Alzheimer's disease but also
collaboratively through the chair
pathology here at Stanford Taman teen
we're also interested in doing a lot of
Parkinson's disease research these these
two these two diseases in particular are
associated with mainly the midbrain and
hippocampus for Parkinson's and
Alzheimer's respectively and so this is
some of the example data I'm going to
show you today a lot of what I'm going
to show is is proof of principle and I'm
gonna show a little bit about the data
and the optimization but to just kind of
more broadly speak about what we're
trying to do with with with Alzheimer's
in particular one really interesting
study that were we're working with folks
at the National Institute of aging on is
this getting at this idea of cognitive
resilience and so one of the things that
you know coming in as someone who has
more of an immunology stem-cell biology
background one of the things I was
really kind of surprised to hear is that
you know neuropathology and that's
associated with Alzheimer's disease
doesn't necessarily always be
to dementia and so you know working
working with some of these ADRC
Alzheimer's disease research consortium
samples what we've what we've identified
is that there are within within within
these patient populations there's uh
there's people who you know at the time
of death when they when they under when
they you know those sort of donated
donated parts of their bodies a science
you have their post-mortem
neuropathology done and you know if they
have no you know beyond regular aging if
they have no neuropathology present for
Alzheimer's disease from the hippocampus
this person almost certainly never has
dementia
however there's often cases when you do
have no pathology where it is typically
associated with cognitive cognitive
decline and so this person will have
documented cognitive defects at the time
of death but there's also a subset of
patients who present with significant
neuropathology who actually at the time
of death were not cognitively impaired
versus what they would what would be the
expectations at that age and so it it
really is it really provides a clinical
backdrop to start to untangle kind of
symptomatic neuropathology from
mechanistic neuropathology so what are
what does the brain look like that's you
know in terms of how do things change
that are just associated with the
process of Alzheimer's disease versus
what are the changes that are required
for Alzheimer's disease to manifest in
terms of cognitive defects or possibly
what are the changes that could manifest
that might be compensatory or corrective
to - maybe avoiding dimension so or hope
we're hoping that by comparing between
these different patient groups we can
start to answer these things and at the
same time by knowing their their jeanna
their their their underlying genotypic
status we can see if there's anything
these processes that are related to say
having the risk gene apoe4
so how we kind of put this together this
has been a bit of an odyssey in the lab
we have that we have we have a really
great team of people of staff scientists
graduate students and postdocs working
on this and you know the goal here and
Anna you know you don't need to really
memorize these panels here but we've
we've we've spent a lot of time trying
to screen and validate FFPE qualified
neuropathology anybody's for use in
multiplex assays and we put together two
panels to really help us kind of target
Alzheimer's disease versus Parkinson's
disease and these two panels aren't
unique there's about there's about just
over 50 unique things kind of here
between the two panels there's so
there's quite a bit of overlap but to
kind of get at the broad themes of some
of the things we're trying to capture
obviously we're trying to capture
neuronal diversity we're trying to
capture things like synaptic markers
both to get an idea of synaptic flavors
but also just an overall idea of
synaptic density because loss of
synaptic density is often associated
with cognitive decline multiple markers
of vasculature so that we can get an
idea of those those types of structures
in the brain where some disease
associated features might be close or
far from vascular vascular defects again
have been potentially associated with
some of these disease processes
obviously starting to look at the other
well I don't want to say accessory cells
because I'm actually quite excited about
the immune cell and glial cell
populations in the brain but you know
capturing your populations of astrocytes
that oligodendrocytes and importantly
microglia and the things that are really
unique in these two panels is going
after the is making sure we can image
the disease associated proteins with
things like ad plaques or Lewy bodies as
well as looking at the protein products
of some of the risk genes like a bowi
for
and so you know I think one of the
things that that that was challenging
early on with this is validation of
these markers you know with a lot of the
tumor immune stuff that I talked about
earlier here we we were able to use a
lot of control immune tissues like
tonsil and lymph node to kind of go and
use the known geography known shapes of
cells to kind of validate things and
it's not that you can't do that here
it's just a lot of the structures in the
brain particularly some of these things
that were non settler features things
like the vasculature that I'm showing
you right here don't have typical shapes
and so it took a little bit of extra you
know elbow grease to kind of get these
things going so so the strategy that we
took for better for worse is again you
know trying to leverage pre-qualified
antibodies that you know people have
already established and used widely get
the metal conjugation on them and then
what we what we would do is we would do
serial analysis our serial sections of
the same control blocks where we would
take one section and we would do regular
single-colored EAB standing that you can
see here in brown and then on the serial
section we would then stain with metal
conjugated anybody alone and run that by
a multiplex ion beam imaging to then
look and see if we got the same map it
got the relatively same distribution of
the marker in the same shapes of the
same signal noise and we've kind of
titrate things accordingly
other markers again disease associated
proteins which can be a little
challenging to see or or plaque
associated proteins plaque associated
proteins are always always challenging
because you don't always know what the
expected plaque density is going to be
and so again making sure that you have
serial sections with both the a B
standing and standard color metric
staining so you can enumerate those
things and then when we look at the
multiplex IB M imaging data making sure
that these things kind of coincide with
one another the other nice thing you can
do with with multiplex imaging is it's
pretty guilt-free or worryfree to throw
in an extra marker that you might have
already evaluated something like I have
a one here which marks our microglia and
we can show that a lot of the a lot of
the apoE staining for instance is is is
showing up in those microglia as we
might expect
the last bit here is again is kind of
going at some of the neural markers and
the neural markers are interesting
because even within even within the body
of a single neuron you can get
differential distribution of these
proteins like v glute wanted to be glue
to so v1 is expected to kind of stain
almost the entire neuronal body where ve
glute 2 is a little more
I call it perinuclear but it's the soma
it's kind of a space immediately around
the nucleus and again you know to really
kind of note you know that you are show
that you know what's going on here and
that things are working properly you
need to be able to kind of stain these
things and scan them at the same time
but also scan them at a reasonable
resolution so you can you can see if
something's perinuclear versus more
diffuse in it standing pattern here so
what does this look like when we put it
through the the whole workflow and here
here what we're showing you or actual
FPE midbrain samples that have been
sectioned onto our conductive slides and
what we're showing here here is in the
top is the pre raster one and then again
like we like I said you know each scan
we take only shaves off a few hundred
diameters of tissue and these are these
are five micron sections and so you can
see after the fact the sample gets a
little discolored but there's still a
lot of material left on the slide and so
we zoom in and we can kind of see where
these two scans are and and just to kind
of orientate with what we're going to be
looking at will be what we can do is is
is kind of look at these scans in terms
of the researched images so it's so much
like we did for the the tumor sample
previously the way this works is we we
we image a whole bunch of five hundred
micron tiles and so we queue these tiles
up such that the 500 micron tiles are
roughly 500 pixels by 500 pixels so
you're dealing with the resolution of
about one micron and these here's this
says R as an array of 252 tiles and were
were we're imaging these to each one of
these tiles in about four minutes so you
know it takes a little while but not too
long it's something you can queue a few
of these
up overnight and then you have your
survey scan so you can go then and
rescan you or your areas of interest and
so the images on the right here what
we're showing you is just one channel
where all the white dots in the tissue
region there are DNA positive nuclei and
that's just a kind of Orient so what
happens when we start overlaying
overlaying our markers well there's kind
of multiple levels to organization in
the brain in particular that I think is
even more I mean much more interesting
than than tumor immunology even here so
so we're gonna start here with kind of
this macro view and there's some things
to pay attention here with this macro
view and you know when you're when
you're judging kind of overall a neuro
phenotypic status you know looking over
a large area understanding the patterns
and restriction of marker expression you
get is a nice thing for validation
showing you know comparing region a
versus region B but also again like I
said for for no pathology looking at
looking at things like you know gain or
loss of certain neural subspecies not
the density's vasculature it's good to
be able to do this in a much larger area
rather than just sampling you know a
couple millimeters worth of image at a
time so in this case this is just
showing the midbrain the the the slice
of the midbrain is really the the panel
on the right here and in particular what
you can see here is my own basic protein
marking a lot of the myelinated material
and then th here this is one of those
ones you'd want to see on the macro
scale for for Parkinson's disease
th is tyrosine hydroxylase that marks
are dopaminergic neurons and you can see
that you can see we can get an overall
kind of view of density of those in the
in the midbrain region there and then G
fab sinestro Civic marker and that's
contrasted by V gap which is which is a
general kind of synaptic vesical marker
that again is giving you an idea of
synaptic density you might have noticed
and this is something that I thought was
kind of pretty but it's kind of like
what the heck is this this funny pattern
you see here highlighted in the white
arrow what this actually is is this is
the optical Noor
orthogonal e coming into the midbrain
and you can see it breaks up the tissue
structure there a little bit so we can
kind of go to level 2 which is I call I
call the micro level and the micro level
is where we start to see things a little
more one cell at a time again you know
you can look at th and we can again get
get an idea about more individual
dopaminergic neurons we can start to
look at like the relationships between
things like gee sap on aesthetic bodies
and c31 marking the different micro
vessels as well as starting to look a
little bit more closely at the
distribution of microglia marked by ib
one cd45 the other cool thing and I'm
going to come to back to it at the very
end is we can start to look at things
like pre and post synaptic markers like
synaptic ice and PSD 95 so synapses Ison
marks most presynaptic bodies but and
PSD 95 tens even though these archives
archival samples they tend to be
positive on as I understand it on
synapses that have recently fired and
and you get the postsynaptic region
being positive for it so it's kind of
cool here because we can kind of go and
go down to the nano scale here where we
take one of these tiles and zoom in a
little bit more on it where you know now
we're dealing with pixels that are more
on the order of 200 to 250 nanometer
resolution and you can start to see the
coincidence of these pre and post
synaptic markers where either they're
overlapping or often just offset a
little bit from one another
going over to the the hippocampus we can
kind of follow the same progression so
again on the hippocampus you can you can
you can see the kind of characteristic
shape here it's a lot easier for me to
identify though it's still tricky
sometimes I need to be told by the neuro
pathologist we work with which which way
I'm looking at it at but you know one of
the one of the hallmarks here you can
see and again this was this was acquired
much the same as we did the midbrain
region here one of the interesting kind
of macro views is is looking at
something like the diseased version of
the the tau protein and one thing you
can see here is with the with with by
kind of quantitatively showing
disdaining in the image you can
see this nice cow gradient where it's
high in the ca1 region and reduces you
kind of go around the corner towards the
gyrus here you see this gradient of the
disease form of tau and that that is
something that normally as I understand
it accumulates with aging and this is
something that gets accelerated when you
have something like Alzheimer's disease
and again you know on the left and right
here you can see the just kind of
distribution of the different neural
markers and you get things like v glue -
which is the perinuclear marker that
marks the neuronal band going around the
hippocampus here as well and again here
on the on the left is just showing you a
light based image of the area that was
scanned that's been mounted on our after
standing on the gold slide so you can
have also a visual visual picture of the
tissue that kind of goes along with
these multiplex imaging imaging files as
well so what happens when we zoom in a
little bit so we can again we can go in
we can kind of pick regions of interest
and we can rescan the the area here that
we're scanning now is closer to this is
this is closer half micron resolution or
we're looking at 500 micron tiles and
where we're scanning at what we're
scanning at approximately a thousand
pixels by a thousand pixels on a 500
micron tile and here again you start to
reveal features of more at the more
cellular level you you have markers
market you have things marking marking
neurons like like any F H and C b56 in
the middle here this is interesting
because we can start to see things like
individual tau tangles showing up and
their relationship to Alzheimer's
associated plaques marked by a beta and
a b8 of 40 and the other kind of
interesting thing is you start to see
look a little more closely and you can
see things like Leo cell markers like
astrocytes and how they're localized
close to vessels indicated here by endo
Glenn CB 105 and they're zoom in a
little bit more we can kind of focus on
one tile where now we're now we're
acquired this is this is this is
this is scanning at our highest
resolution setting which is closed for
about 250 nanometer pixels and you can
really start to reveal the granularity
of what's going on and this is looking
right in the kind of bend the dentate
gyrus area of the hippocampus here and
just a few interesting little bits to
point out we've got transcription factor
again marking the neuronal nuclei and
you can start to see kind of the
distribution of micro biomarkers versus
a lot of the neuronal processes in that
tissue but I think my favorite picture
is when we you know we can this is just
looking at a couple colors at a time but
when we look at a few other channels you
can see again the the neurons they're
marked by the purple v glue - one of the
interesting things here is you see this
all the holes in the tissue again these
are these are this is baskets or
microvascular turns you get a really
nice idea about how all of the
astrocytes you know wrap around this a
scripture to help form the blood-brain
barrier and this is something that you
know what we're playing around with the
idea of how we can kind of capture and
quantify these things and understand how
intact features like this in the tissue
are and how they change with our
different patient control groups one of
the other things I wanted to talk about
quickly before before we kind of end off
is what are some of the things we're
thinking about doing analytically with
this data so kind of contrast with what
we showed originally with the tumor
immunology stuff you know but the tumor
immunology stuff and the tissue immune
immune work is is relatively more
straightforward in that I think there's
no disagreement that you know
identifying and segmenting cells and
extracting those cells understanding
their identity and then relating that
identity and other expression features
back to spatial information the tissue
is a really nice workflow with the brain
as you guys saw from a lot of these
images you know well you can see nuclei
and we can see individual cells a lot of
the brain is is is not necessarily
extrasolar tissue but it's only parts of
cells because not all the cells some of
the cells are quite large and they exist
across multiple planes in the brain and
so it's in
of just extracting cells which i think
is important we also are starting to
think about what other features do we
extract for instance like the vascular
and blood-brain features or in this case
something like synaptic features because
well assessing overall synaptic density
is important it's also probably
interesting to just extract synapses the
same way we do extract cells and treat
them like populations understand what
the composition composition localization
is because that might have some
information and there's in there too and
you know then the good news is for this
just like it was with a lot of the
antibodies and reagents that we're
leveraging to do these assays is that
people have thought about this problem
already and they've thought about it
using fluorescence technology so this is
just one example of a paper this is
something Brian cannon a PhD student my
lab is working on where we're taking
these computational pipelines that have
been built out for light based imaging
and enumeration of things like synapses
and trying to apply them to maybe data
and again to make a long story short
what this does is it essentially goes
through and leverages the fact that we
can that we can image these things
simultaneously and that you should see
either direct print pixel coincidence or
pixel neighborhood coincidence of these
features in an image and so then what we
can do is we can go in and define our
synaptic markers for instance like
synapses bison and PSD 95 here we can go
through and the algorithm can assign on
a kind of pixel by pixel basis a
probability of whether or not it's a
synapse we can then you know using our
quantitative feel and the quality
quantity are the qualitative field on
the quantitative score that we get we
can then go define cut-offs and have
things actually assigned as being part
of a synaptic event or not and so in
this case is just zooming in and showing
you features where we see sent up to Phi
sin and PSD 95 co-expressed
and the white pixels have been kind of
enumerated here as being being positive
for a snap and so again this is just an
idea we're just like you would segment
cells from an image we can segment and
identify other interesting neuronal
features like synaptic bodies or
vesicles that we can also kind of
extract and compare between our patient
groups to see where what the differences
are in composition localization and
abundance
so with that said this has been a lot of
work by a lot of people in the lab we've
been developing the imitation here for
quite a while and all the maybe stuff
has done in in collaboration with my
partner in crime like Angelo who's right
down from the hall hall from us we
worked with Stephen Thompson who's very
charming physicist who helped us design
a lot of this early instrumentation and
kind of make it a reality
Leah Caron is a talented computational
biologist in the lab who's been who has
done a lot of the early analytical work
on the tumor immune micro environment
stuff and a lot of the work with the
brain data we've been you leveraging her
pipelines to also do analysis there
because Ali as you can see with her
holding the picture of the brain there
she's the captain of the brain team this
is unfortunately an outdated slide so I
don't have pictures of some of the other
brain team folks but we've got JP
Olivieri for a postdoc from from
McMaster University in Canada dunya
Miran came to us from from Europe and
she's here working between my love until
Montagnes lab and Brian Cannon who's the
PhD student in our computational systems
immunology program who's been working on
the neural stuff and Mark blesse of
course who helps keep everything maybe
running in the lab as well and with that
I think we have time for some questions
Thank You Sean for your presentation a
quick reminder for our audience on how
to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left to your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
Sean will answer as many questions as
time permits so let's get started our
first question is can you provide more
detail on the sample preparation such as
section thickness sure yeah I mean
that's an interesting one with the with
the brain samples in general so
everything that we showed here in this
presentation was 5 micron tissue
sections and that as I understand it
working with the neuropathology team at
Stanford is pretty standard one thing
we've been playing around with more but
I don't have any data to show for yet is
playing around with bickered thicker
sections where we're trying to kind of
capture cells that don't necessarily fit
in plain I think you probably noticed in
some of the images with a lot of things
like microglial markers you only saw
bits of cells coming through and that's
because we're only imaging a few hundred
dinah meters at a time so I think with
you know with potentially with thicker
sections you know you could image more
and get the whole cell body or even do
some stuff that I didn't show here today
but we're even playing around with
things like 3d reconstructions so you
know but for now pretty standardized C
protocols seem to work well with it
on our next question what are the
biggest challenges with data analysis
um the the I think with the data
analysis particularly with the neural
pathology I was kind of alluding to it
at the end of the presentation there so
like I showed at the beginning you know
with something like the tumor
microenvironment and epithelial tissues
and immune cells when you image a plane
of a sample a two-dimensional plane you
can pretty readily in those types of
tissues identify cell nuclei and that
extract cell you know an entire segment
of a cell based on the nuclei of cell
borders and that that allows you to
extract most of what you've imaged in in
one of those sections and so then once
you've extracted a single cell you can
then kind of feed those single cells
into I don't want to say run-of-the-mill
but you know already established kind of
single cell analysis pipelines where you
can then add your your spatial
information is another dimension into
the analysis with the brain material I
think one of these you might have noted
when looking at the kind of survey scans
of the hippocampus and the midbrain when
we look at the nuclear markers the data
is you know in terms of cell nuclei in
the brain they're quite sparse there's a
lot of non-nuclear non-current nuclear
material there right so segmenting an
intact cell out of the brain you can you
can do it but when you do that there's a
lot of material left unsegmented and so
when you I think one of the things we've
been thinking about is what are those
other things what are those other kind
of micro scale nano scale features that
could be related to neurobiology
neuropathology
that aren't don't fit into a traditional
cell segmentation box and so that's
where we're starting to think about
leveraging multiplex features to extract
things like synapses extract things like
disease associated protein so going
after like Lewy bodies and plaques and
both annotating them as being there or
not there but also starting to
quantitatively look at their composition
with respect to the relative proteins
that form them
excuse me also using markers like CV 31
and endo Glyn to get at the vasculature
and the types of as mature and then
starting to ask questions around what's
the localization of some of these other
features like cells or like disease
associate protein to the basket sir and
so it it's definitely I think my
intuition is that the neural pathology
is going to be more challenging than the
standard tumor immunology stuff but I
also think it's kind of exciting because
you know working with the
neuropathologists that we do there's a
lot of stuff outside of just looking at
neurons that they're excited to look at
and see if it's associated with
different disease groups here and so I
think you know employing you know the
same segmentation pipelines but thinking
about new things to segment is going to
be one thing the other thing that's
really wide open is going you know pure
data different current analysis taking
machine learning approaches and and
using sort of computer vision to find
other features we might not think to
segment out of the image to start
comparing our disease groups as well now
our next question can you look at other
models that could be involved in
neurological disease
that that you know it's funny I I get
that question a lot when I've been
showing this data and the short answer
is yes I don't think you can look at I'm
not sure we can look at every metal
because different metals have different
ionization potentials but one I've
gotten asked about a lot is iron and I
don't have the I didn't I didn't have
that data in this presentation but in
that same paper we have in revision
right now one of the things that we
showed is when you're looking at various
tissues you can see you can see high
levels of iron in tissue resident
macrophages that are doing better I
think essentially consuming a lot of red
blood cells and then we see a lot of
protein components that would be
associated with those say macrophages
and red blood cells in those in those
same spaces and so I think the short
answer is yes I think the challenge was
looking at other endogenous metals
especially metals that are expected to
be in biologic tissues but also more
higher abundantly in in the general
environment it's just being really
careful with sample preparation and
stuff like that because one of the
things we were worried about is you know
we use steel blades to cut our tissue
sections which have iron in them and so
we want to make sure that the iron were
imaging is iron in our sample and not
iron that we've introduced through some
means but yeah I think that's really I
think that's a really good question I
think that's something we want to look
at and the good news is is you know with
the imaging instrumentation we're
basically collecting the entire
elemental mass spectra from you know one
to two hundred and so we can pick any
max channel that we want to extract for
certain ice and hope and see if that
isotopes there any reasonable button
now how many signals at a time can we
measure from one side from the slide
yeah so in terms of in-house testing
that we've done I think we've gotten
we've gotten about 53 individual
isotopes working I don't know the exact
number four what's commercially
available but I think it's somewhere
around 42 or 43 mass channels can be
kind of purchased and used all the data
I showed you today was I think
approximately 40 Plex gain and it's kind
of one of those things where they're
they're theirs
there there is there's a diminishing
returns with some potential new metal
channels you can use because not
basically there's a lot of things we can
measure where we don't necessarily have
the chemistry to attach them to a probe
in the right form like we could use you
know we can measure iron like I was just
saying but we we don't have a good way
to use iron as a reporter because I
can't attach iron to an antibody very
well but in terms of things that we have
good chemistry for that that you know
work with commercial reagents you know
most of our experiments are in the 40 to
45 Plex range
on our next question actually has a
couple questions so we're going to start
with the first one how long does it take
for imaging the 252 tiles that's really
good that's a good yeah so I tried I
really tried my best to kind of state
imaging times as I was going through but
yeah there is a there is a inverse
exponential relationship between imaging
time and imaging resolution
so with those 252 tiles where we're
imaging it like micron resolution each
one of those tiles takes about one hour
set up with our kind of exposure time it
took takes about four minutes tile so I
should have I should have this number
written down but you're looking at
you're looking at you're looking at a
couple of hours per survey scan and so
like I said we usually queue up some of
those tile runs over overnight so about
a thousand minutes however many however
many hours that would be for 250 tile
scan now the next part of this of this
question what is the maximum
multiplexing done in neuropath studies
I mean I think you just thought that
that you know I feel like I said before
we we've got chemistry working for about
53 simultaneous reporters that we can
probe for in the lab for the most part
though the majority of Explo of
experiments sit between 40 plus and 45
flex where where we got one exit Oak
assigned to one antigen I think there
are ways to use spatial multiplexing and
bar coding to push that higher but if
you're assigning one antigen for one
reporter where most of our experiments
said the toss it around the for the
forty Plex image analysis range
and the last part is you mentioned
imaging plaques was challenging is there
there any picture that you can share of
plaques with MIB I
about plaque itself yeah there was I
mean again in that presentation there
was a few plaques in there I don't think
I had any zoomed in pictures there's
some stuff so all the data they showed
today was really optimization data for
paper that we're putting together right
now we're we're we're looking at control
healthy and establish diseased tissues
just kind of as a proof of principle for
[Music]
for for you know seeing if we can reveal
you know either
expected or potentially new disease
hallmarks when looking at things like
eighty at PD I don't have I don't at
this moment have a ready zoomed in photo
but I think if you go back in or contact
me directly I might be happy to you know
see if I can dig something up to show
you more or even send you a preprint at
the paper we are looking at higher res
versions of this stuff
Shawn how long does a scam take
so the I think that was kind of that was
kind of asked already but in terms of
the standards there's there's two
there's there's kind of multiple levels
of how long does it fit so for the
survey scans at micron resolution we can
scan you know we can scan at one to two
thousand pixels per second we're you
know a given tile only has you know only
has a few thousand pixels in it so those
can be scanned relatively quickly right
for the higher resolution scans that we
were showing near the end where we're
looking at the damaged iris scanning at
standing at about 250 nanometer
resolution because the I n dose is much
smaller and we're sputtering less
material off the slide we tended dwell
longer with each pixel and on top of
that we're making more pixels because
the high resolution image so in those
case of those 250 nanometer images we're
looking at I'm actually I'm literally
typing this out of my card later right
now we're looking at somewhere around
about an hour hour hour and a half for
tile because we're dwelling we're
dwelling for for more like 4 to 6
milliseconds per pixel so it does take
longer to do those ones but that's why
we that's why we kind of like this kind
of scan rescan approach because with the
brain just looking at the growth
neuropathology it's sometimes difficult
just from the slide to kind of pick the
right area to scan to high resolution so
we'll do that survey scan in 40
dimensions look at relative areas of
interest and then go back and we can
rescan kind of the next the next layer
to make sure that we're hitting the
right anatomical features yeah so it can
like I said we can know we can generate
a survey scan in one of those tiles in
minutes or we can scan it at higher
resolution at higher sensitivity and do
it a little bit slower but you you
generate kind of richer images like I
showed you there at the end
now Shawn we have another three-part
question the first part is do you do you
only use markers for different cell
types
um I would say well no we don't I think
a lot of a lot of the markers we use
didn't necessarily go after just
different cell types I think the way we
the way we typically design these
studies upfront and the way we went at
this one is we tried to think the
matically about what aspects of biology
are involved in neuropathology emergen
right and so this is where we thought
there was like that immune or glial cell
component so of course we got markers
for those cells there's obviously a
neuronal component so you have to mark
all your neurons but then there's all of
these things where you've got you know
things like synapses which are parts of
cells but are almost an independent
regulatory features so we start you know
adding in synaptic markers and then you
start to get into kind of non synoptic
things where we start like like the
previous question mentions we start
looking at proteins that are associate
with plaques as well as proteins
associated with vasculature and so on so
it's not just about capturing cells
themselves but for whatever your tissue
is and experiment is you want to capture
other facets of biology at the same time
because I think it's not just about
enumerated all these things
independently but in the spatial context
understanding how they might be related
to one another at the same time and so
you got to kind of do that that the
other thing that we've done and driven
for a lot of these analysis is we kind
of pair up with a lot of research
studies which I didn't kind of go into
today where people are using orthogonal
technologies things like nuke seek and
single file RNA seek they identify new
genes that might be associated with new
cell types and then we try to devise
probes again those new genes or new cell
types to again put them back into the
context of the tissue were already
imaging
now how do you use histological imaging
to do confirmation of cell types
um yeah I so I mean most of the time
it's pretty straightforward we we
usually go back to the original FFP
blocks that we got our cell types are
our images off of and we'll take a
serial section and then we'll often
probe the serial section of that same
block and either use the same reagent
with chromogenic stains or we'll use
chroma Jetix day in itself like silver
staining or something that you'd more
traditionally used to kind of identify
cell types by morphology instead of a
marker so we kind of try to use these
orthogonal complementary techniques
where we will put on the same sample
substrate
and then the last question is how do you
do image overlay
so for image overlay the good news is so
for the serial sections it's kind of
hard to do you know for for if you're
talking about in terms of the controls
that I was showing there you know we
can't really take one section and image
if I may be and another section do da be
thinning and expect to overlays up and
match things up for all the other images
I showed you I think the important thing
to know just in case there was a
misunderstanding here is there is no
image overlay all the features and all
the parameters are acquired
simultaneously in the same pixel so the
image off the instrument is a single a
single image where the different layers
of the images is the different layers of
the image are just the different mass
channels we've extracted and there's no
overlay or scooching of multiple layers
involved the only kind of overlaying and
alignment that we have to do if you are
getting us for this is for the tiling
and for the tiling approach this is this
is something where to you know full
disclosure I say the jury is still out
on it we are playing around with two
types of tiling one type of tiling I'll
call it clean edge tiling where we
literally tile edge to edge and we don't
have any overlap and then we count on
the accuracy of the stage and the
instrument stepping to be good enough
that we can basically put the squares
back together without any overlap that's
looking really promising but you get you
still get some artifacts where you know
the stage doesn't step perfectly and
maybe things are a little bit out alive
the other type of overlap we do is what
how most of the images were generated
here which is we have we we specifically
build in an overlap of a few microns on
kind of the right and lower edge of each
tile and then we have a little algorithm
that kind of overlaps and lines those
things back together based on high
abundant markers so we can stitch those
multi tile images and then we use some
pretty standard noise removal approaches
to kind of take the extra signal out of
the overlap part which is again this
isn't something that this is nothing
that we invented these are this is
really borrowing from the toolbox that
people who do
regular light-based my crops we have
been using for years
is the conjugation chemistry you are
referring to based on the ion ion path
kids
so the yeah so for the images that I
show today the all the reagents that we
use to generate those images were all
we're all used we're all the reagents
that we use to generate the images were
all created using the ion path education
trip
now for the images that you showed did
you apply the denoising the background
subtraction algorithm that was published
in the recent cell paper another really
good question
so actually a lot of the images I showed
for the brain data had very little
denoising done to them because the noise
filtering for the in the cell paper was
a K nearest neighbors so that works
really well when you've got a lot of
kind of signal concentrated to like a
cell body or a nucleus or a membrane one
of the issues so not all you know so
some of the images were denoise using
that but some of the more abundant
widely expressed markers but then some
of the markers like the synaptic markers
that I showed near the end there those
weren't denoise at all because those are
actually more sparse markers where a lot
of the lot of what we think is real
signal might actually get removed during
denoising and so instead what we're
using for those images is more feature
extraction based approach where we look
at coincidence of multiple markers that
we expect to be within the same pixel or
within the same pixel neighborhood and
we kind of use that to identify and
extract the features so it's a little
bit of a little bit of both but I think
the good news is is with a lot of the
you know newer instrumentation we've
been working with and the you know
optimization of the assays up front
Enders there's really very little noise
in the raw data that we collected and so
you know again if you went back and look
at those those neuronal
synapse images at the very end of the
presentation most of the pixels are
black because there's just no signal
there put a good question
we have had some amazing questions today
but it looks like we only have time for
one more so we'll finish with this one
do you use any matrix for the tos and if
so is there any matrix related issues on
FFPE tissues for nonspecific signals
yeah
so um so for the matrix thing we we the
only matrix in our assay is the tissue
itself I think I think the person asking
a question might be making analogous
comparisons to something like MALDI
imaging so MALDI imaging is a soft
ionization approach where you're looking
at kind of de novo proteins in the
sample and for that you do overlay a
chemical matrix on the sample to help
preserve larger molecules during the
ionization analysis process in our case
all we do is a standard IHC workflow
where we've got our element conjugated
antibodies they stay in the tissue and
the primary ion beam imaging there's no
laser or anything involved that the I am
beam is a much harder ionization process
it sputters off those elements those
those those reporter ions as elemental
atoms already so there there's there's
nothing we've we've added in and because
of that there's not a lot of matrix
effects we've tested a basically every
tissue in the body through these assays
and I think because most human tissues
are made of carbon nitrogen oxygen and
hydrogen there's very little and
chemically the assay doesn't know the
difference of whether we're looking at
gut or brain or breast so generally
there is no matrix effects but again
it's something is an important thing to
ask when you're doing things like
sentence
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on Saban's period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information provided at the time
of registration we would also like to
once again thank Sean for his
presentation and thank our sponsor ion
paths for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through August of 2019
lever to alert you via email and it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye